udr c squeeze aujourd'hui on se trouve
sur l'alfa d'euros de redemption qui est
un jeu que vous m'avez conseiller parce
qu ils assez bourrin c'est un jeu de
voitures et motos
alors pourquoi il ya une musique douce
sur le menu est ce qu'on va troller as
qu'on m'a bien trop les encore une fois
on y va ou quoi faut que je termine
premier ou deuxième
déjà en bas à droite je vois qu on a eu
besoin de deux bateaux à clouange peut
être des coups très bien je vois où ils
veulent en venir un homme à cette
violence
waouh je te calmes a lui aussi fait du
groupe
mais non mais c'est scandaleux attendait
un halo mais qu'il a carrément une faute
je ne sais pas trop quoi au nom tout va
très bien je suis juste dernier tout va
pas bien faut que les élimine auj ces
plaques avonex mais sans aucune raison
le haut c'est même qu'est ce qui leur
arrive à ces gens au plat au plateau
lance effectivement nous avait pas menti
c'est bien violent hop là tu vas où mon
gars c'est génial valence pas bien du
tout un quelle violence je suis outré
hop là allez c'est pour mieux à quoi la
place c'est ça qu'on voulait faut que je
déconne cinq motards oger saab csu
ballerines version moto que la voiture
hop au film apparaît comme le chevalier
paul voss la double à la matraque génial
pas je veux dire en quelle violence
il fait quoi il saute mais non mais faut
pas sauter mon gars ben oui on travaille
ces motards on tape ont bien appris leur
leçon est la leçon un peu brutale quand
même un la leçon tu ressortent à pas mal
de bleu ok c'est parti on attendait
c'est quoi là qu'on a c'est une bourde
au oui on attend c'est qui ok je crois
qu'on donne des bombes à la fois c'était
pour être en accord avec lui son vol
plané factor ça a pété
non mais faut pas rêver il m'a fait nos
vous êtes trompés colis tenait monsieur
non non c'était bien votre colis [ __ ]
c'est génial comme je salut ça va a pas
cette fois ce qu'il faut que termine
premier je crois quand même c'est quand
même une course à la base a plus qu'un
défouloir
non tiens je voulais finir premier bah
je suis premier ah bah oui c'est un flic
devant il n'est pas dans la course lui
ou alors le flic carrément chez nous et
qu'on allait alors niveaux suivants
attends attends attends attends huawei
moreau
ça devait finir comme ça qu'est ce qui
se passe devant pour voir calme et bon
mais on est sur des routes père de
william circulation comme s'ils étaient
dans paris quoi et en des premières
n'empêche un ballon vous à tous les gars
et c'est la première place
terminer premier ou deuxième à lasser le
mode où il ya plein plein plein de
voitures sur la route c'est bien ça me
plaît ça mais ça c'est jackson commence
à la jackson depuis de forest ce qu'il a
pris dans la gueule aux ouailles importe
quoi sa voiture c'est scandaleux a été
belle
mon pauvre gars ont une belle attaque à
l'appel de m tu fais quoi à mon gars
mais tu connais pas l'homme elle appelle
bas où j'étais chez ma copine vous un
petit peu de jardinage que je rentre en
moto et ben je m'appelle c'est tout à ça
fait du bien de gagner 1 ou tu en as
juste de la dynamite bonbons aux as tu
cook et il m'a donné son sa matraque le
mec me remets dans l'explosion il
m'envoie sa matraque avec avec un petit
mot disant tiens bien joué et touche
très fair play comme comme flic tu fais
qu un plus qu'à mais pourquoi pas celui
là
allez va mal tu veux steven bombe à en
voici en voilà moi je fabrique des
bombes chez moi c'est mon hobby ok faut
que j'aille jusqu'au croire aux faut que
j'aille jusqu'au point b sans mourir
pour mais qu'est ce qui se passe avec
ses bouts action ça ne suffit plus
d'avoir des accidents sur la route pas
postes dans des accidents dans l'ère de
la route à temps parce que je te
plumerai c'est ma route déjà fasse pas
la mienne fiscale mais c'est scandaleux
de faire des choses comme ça oh mon dieu
chose je crois qui se mange et vu qu'il
est plus là scandaleux mais arrêtez
messieurs dames arrêter la vitesse avant
toute chose s'est elle m'a volé ma peine
il va vous les appels fosse où il
appelle assez bougée l'appel geogres
escargots quelqu'un tout ça pour une
belle cause
c'est très tendu à temps mais je me suis
mangé au moins six bagnoles sont
j'allais mourir quoi au le skill coucou
à temps mais ça est faux cadavres qu'il
est dans un jeu d'horreur doit carrément
la voiture qui fait peur la voiture
screamer le scream car voilà et c'est le
cube
ouais bien jouer au caire avait la
voiture fait un tremplin finalement donc
là il faut que je finisse premier au
deuxième et tous les véhicules me
déteste le petit job coups de pelle à
l'arrivée coups de pelle à l'arrivée
j'ai dit
non soirée ils posent des bombes
maintenant qu'est ce que c'est que ça
aille aide
merrett mais c'est pas faire pour les
arrêter avec ces passionnés
mesdames et messieurs plein boom mais
laissez moi je m'en vais scandaleux ça
aussi mais non mais ça commence
wray tu arrêtes juste pour me guy 18 le
jeu peine 18 pequiven de même voire même
payer 60 arrêter sinon jarry votre
carrosserie avec rappel savait pas qui
je suis moi on m'appelle belle aux
motards alors ça vous en bouche à quoi
bon pas bon il ya aucun couac est bouché
je m'excuse c'est l'arrivée on est 3e on
a perdu première défaite voilà voilà il
se soucie attendait mais c'est super
violent ce mode non il a voulu mettre
une bombe à j'ai vu c'était pas un gant
qu'ils avaient non ce n'est pas un gant
en cuir c'est une bombe
allez vas t'en rends non non mais pas ça
je m'en vais au leskiw toi j'arrête à
carrosserie up la petite rayure toi je
la reille up la petite rayure à l'appel
pourra dire que clp le monde tu te
l'afex up la rayure tu en arrives et non
non aux pompes à l'arrivée on prend le
vide
cette fois c'est bon flic son look bon
[ __ ] mais ces festivals ils sont là
juste pour le spectacle laisse près des
voitures et nous on applaudissait ça
arrive et où es tu salut camionnette
elle est là bas voilà le film s'il te
plaît cette bouffée d'air frais assez
bon on a fini on est retournés d'ivoire
ça me donne juste envie de me venger sur
celui qui m'a mis quelques bombes je
crois que c'est lui je le reconnais à sa
veste au plat tu t'en vas y mon gars tu
as voulu mou du foot c'est mon cas qu à
vous le donner aux français voilà je
compte des amis
tu fais quoi un coup de bell tu fais
quoi à coude je suis le samouraï
tout droit venu de chevalerie médiévale
warfare j'ai mon sabre chica chica au
revoir à cannes qu'un bon je suis bien
meilleur la queue de cheval rien mais
bon ça va leur dire catchy en l'air au
c'était beau tu as voulu doubler ça
m'aurait de shibari mondiaux valoir sa
télé dans la salle
c'est beaucoup trop long comme frappe
puis là-bas il a une tête à bomber ça se
voit c'est déjà assez comme les tête à
chapeaux oui c'est tata bon ben voilà
bon c'est un peu moins cool que tête à
chapeaux et qui met des photos où il
fait semblant de partir dans l'est dans
le décor quoi on se fait un petit kiff
hors piste voilà après voilà on
roula de caméras mais bon oh c'est beau
très beau comme explosion tue moi je
suis un expert en explosion et ça c'est
vraiment joli kouao les deux noms être
trop gourmand tu finis par te prendre
une deuxième voiture
et voilà sur ses bienfaits de cette
vidéo sur la foi de rhodes redemption
merci de l'avoir conseiller parce qu'il
est franchement marrant un mélange de
burn out et de bomberman jeu s'appelle
comme d'habitude j'espère que ça vous a
plus ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ou à faire un scrabble avec vos grands
parents chez soi vous êtes passé un très
bon week-end et que personne n'arrivait
votre voiture avec une pelle un ce
serait très mal ou est sûr c'est pas moi
alors je vous promets on se retrouve
très vite dans sa nouvelle vidéo chat ou
le monde dise
[Musique]